yeah welcome to this video was this
another five-minute blitz game against
Danny men ten off one game ahead against
him which i won okay yeah this Center I
don't know really the name others open
sometimes called the center game which
is kind of a strange name right what
exactly does this mean the center game
um ok night a three that's a rare move
they play Knight to c3 all the time I
wonder hmm what happens if I do this
actually out for Bishop c5 attacking
them checking f2 how does he protect
that interesting ok i can i can take f2
now mmm i go f6 he's out to protected
with bishop h flan but Bishop f2 Queen
f2 hmm that's not too great right I'm a
piece down after that mmm
why very strange stuff really have a
hard time to believe in all that yeah
for widely but Bishop f2 really doesn't
seem to work maybe I can play that and
then f6 I am probably not very strange
very strange I mean this isn't
particularly bad for me but then it's
not what I what I wanted quite weird
yeah so what do I do now don't want to
play 94 yet attack his Queen and he has
to go to d3 but after that I don't
really see a great continuation so
probably just get my development
completed here with Bishop to e6 plane
almost let's say I wonder ever had some
kind of representation there off the
strange play but um
after Bishop g5 it seemed I had no
better move taking on f2 wasn't working
I'm trying to gain some space here and
if possible trying to prevent a form
aged 5 g 3 h 5 foam interesting ok
that's an interesting way to play
complicated g 3 h 4f for Queen g7 is an
interesting continuation ok it's not
really going for any of that ok I can go
back here g6 is not a bad spot for the
night anyway Amy 45 would like to get it
to e5 of course but taking on 26 I think
was too irritating ok ok let's push it
forward
yeah off to off to e5 if possible okay
so he doesn't mind that at all strangely
enough giving me the square someone to
f6 and then 95 I guess I think he
probably wants to go on night to be five
here okay maybe go a six not not a happy
move it looks like it might give him
some ok this is still nice really with
the porn wow that looks entirely wrong
just even I mean even technically it
looks wrong strategically it also is
wrong but but technically I just win win
stuff here right f 2 i'm not winning
just f 2 million okay so what now we
need another pawn or trade queens and
trading queens is probably probably
simplest i have a pawn up already so
there's no need for for winning more
material really just back and then get
the King to e7 go from there
I wonder look before might have been
interesting maybe I'm I should prevent
that for the time being put it on a five
be six ideas rook h6 f6 for a rope trade
he goes yeah I can do this now basically
forcing the rook trade taking yeah why
not I can just take King up for night
496 and now I can get an f5 right and
five king of 696 check it should be
should be good f5 he's got no it's got
Bishop d3 maybe I have to be a bit
cautious than that I'm not tied morning
yeah that I'm not blundering into some
kind of wacky endgame okay mad now
Bishop e3 at a king opponent games with
extra points are almost always winning
but check you have to be oh I overlooked
this one hmm ok ok it's not it's not the
end of the world because I'm I win stuff
on the queenside but I didn't intend
that absolutely not mmm we should be
seven
I have to take it b5 Bishop chinks maybe
that's not easy not easy at one now I
mean I totally miss played that white of
the slim should be some unbelievable
what a joke what a joke our played this
end game yeah next time I should go for
warm-up games what a ridiculous loss
came black resides yeah I think this is
just just entire it we had very weird to
lose that yeah okay f5 was a tricky move
I mean I was only thinking about Bishop
d3 not about Bishop e8 um yeah probably
i just wind with northernmost king of
six or something regrouping the night
jam
that was very stupid some nights sick
skinny form how do I win from them yeah
it takes a bit of patience here but it
should be okay the h5 pawn in this
situation you cannot attack you know and
i get i get 96 kingi 497 may be up to f5
hey it's not so easy to win this ok I
see a way now to win this it's something
like that yeah night here um maybe I
don't know what he's doing and he cannot
do much I'm doing the same thing
basically and whatever he does like here
you go here mmm I don't know this is
blundering the porn so I don't know this
ego ce4 here putting something more on
moonlight squares I don't know yeah
something like this let's say and then
I'm going here and then f5 check and
over to f6 this should be M should be M
should be enough really can he can
hinder that for a moment like here he is
still not f5 huh
that's surprisingly difficult to win I
don't get a five and easily hmm
and now I don't see a clear way to win
that there should be something but I
don't I don't see it I really don't see
a way to win this um can I go no one
cannot he always has this Bishop d7 idea
to block at five
and I senior win in this position maybe
this isn't isn't that easy let's go back
a little bit I mean maybe it's a it's a
matter of being a little bit more
precise here if I play and now it's not
it's not so clear that is very logical
to treat the rooks there
hmm now I don't see you in maybe this is
in fact maybe this is a draw it's a bit
strange been a bit weird and hard to
believe maybe it is or can I do
something entirely different okay let's
say he goes like this um I mean if I
just stay put i can now obviously never
lose so maybe I can try it tries to do
something with the night down invading
or something mmm but I don't don't
really see if I'm getting anywhere I can
put this is looking crazy i can put the
night on age three and then try to go
for f5 is this any good it might be
interesting might be interesting let's
just just try just destroy what happens
here okay yeah if an idea to check so it
cannot do that let us say he does this
like here i'm going here and let's say
he goes back here yeah then i have 92
nite here this is an additional idea of
the night here controlling f4 instead of
the night on g6 controlling f4 so he has
to somehow stay put here and if i now
can i now get in at five yeah now i get
in at five this is interesting high five
King III kingi 5m and that's it should
be aired still Bishop you aid king okay
I can go to e7 maybe like here
and just that I have f1 igg1 what was
very tricky this end game very very
tricky but this is this is a thang an
idea putting the night on that we at
square h 3 I can you can even argue that
maybe I should should do this move on
because this is um a bit a bit of a
night's not a Zook so I can go here now
I can go down yeah then I'm probably
still on I have to go at five otherwise
I'm not okay here King f5 maybe but
probably something like this and now
King f7 e7 mixer here here still I'm not
totally positive how I'm winning yeah
I'm covering those squares
hmm
hi it's still not not so clear really
maybe I can can get the night back
somehow yeah so sorry about that yeah
but okay I think this end game is
probably be too too tricky to completely
underlies thanks for watching us